[Music]
hello everybody and welcome to
insensitivity training I'm court McGowan
I'm Joe bartnik and today we have I
think we have maybe the king of
insensitivity I know I think maybe I
said a lot of people you have you have
over the but in a nice way in a bad way
women I want to welcome to the podcast a
hero of both Joe's mine mr. Jim Jeffries
welcome hello thank you for having me
yeah thank you for having us we're in
your estate on Mount Olympus yeah it's I
can't even breathe up here yeah it's
very nice yeah I used to this is I
waited he's like I leave only a thousand
meters above sea level or whatever I
could tell like as my GPS says I'm right
right your GPS is from England it's from
Italy oh really oh okay but it's not
Americanized
oh it's American oh oh so but it goes
meters no guys fate you need to convert
he's pop every time I Drive up here
right and I was just we just did a bus
to her I mean far I sure did a bus to
her and we were driving along the
Rockies and you know obviously the bus
and ran around the corner I rolled out
of bed 20,000 feet up nice panicky wake
up did you wake up right away or to take
a little bite hit the floor oh yeah hey
while they make my girlfriend Mikey blue
on the bus as well so I was sleeping in
a bunk for a lot of it I didn't even get
the bed at the back
oh that's see that's not fair it's
amazing to me now after doing that to
understand like how any band stays
together unless you're so successful
that each one of you gets your own bus
right yeah [ __ ] do these people live for
months that's why you have to make it
before you're like 23 24 25 because then
you're like I'm not doing this anymore
yeah I'm the same way it's like I just
it's like going going especially shitty
hotels and stuff like that it's like you
get
oddly enough as shitty as you get as I
get treated sometimes even as a feature
on the road or whatever
you always get put up in a decent hotel
yeah they always they always the club's
generally I'll say 95% of the club's put
you up in a pretty pretty decent hotel
even Doubletree up yeah yeah double tree
is good you get the cookie yeah yeah and
from the hated try and you like all
right or or there or the hotel is so
close to the club you can throw a rock
and hit it in it so it's like you're
alright alright whatever it doesn't
matter you go back and it's got that
little shop oh yeah then there's no one
there and it's kind of just like a
buffet don't even want to steal you like
you're taking mini boxes of Froot Loops
yeah microwave Philly cheesesteak and
you're like alright this is me I was
little microwave white castle's nothing
to microwave the right like oh yeah like
the bun in the meat yeah I was working
with dice Andrew Dice Clay one time we
did this because they know you say dice
alright well anyway so I was working I
was working with dice and we were in
this casino in Oklahoma and he went
through and they had one of those little
mini little places and he just got a
baggie and he just opened the baggie and
he just started shoving all this stuff
in there I mean he took almost
everything that was on the Shelf like
five Reese's butterfingers Snickers he
just put them all in the bag and he
walked by and the guy was standing there
at the front desk he goes it's four dice
and he just walked up to his room like
what are you gonna do anyways I don't
like American chocolate this is what the
one thing that's stopping me from
getting fat in this country if you have
lost some weight I go up and down I
haven't lost anything intentionally I
workout but it's it's a [ __ ] headand
of 40 it's a struggle wait okay wait
till you start getting closer to 50 it's
beyond a struggle but you know when you
get like people in their 20s that's just
like you know I try not to eat after
and you're like no no you don't get it
it just gets harder it's long I
understand the principle that if you if
you burn more calories than you eat
you'll lose weight I get it
right but it used to be like I could
just take calories and not more exercise
and I'd still keep my weight down you'd
be fine yeah it doesn't work that way
anymore no it stays and it stays and
then all sudden you're going like wait a
second I finished that half gallon ice
cream and I don't feel so good in and
you wake up the next thing you go I
still feel fat and it's all everyday
things like that why he's like half a
pound with everything on it right and
then I weigh more I gained a pound in
weight that doesn't seem right I'm
getting more than the actual weight of
the food if the way yourself the first
thing in the morning yeah that's the
lowest you are yeah that's what they say
I don't know every like 18 months I go
up ten pounds to my natural weight like
you know what I think 270 do I think
that's where I think it's where it fit
naturally at yeah do you why your shits
are why my [ __ ] you do yeah what what I
do is even nicer toilets the way myself
in the morning then I have a [ __ ] that I
weigh myself again hobby oh we should or
you consider doing that you could just
[ __ ] into a bag and just way that [ __ ] I
know me piece of [ __ ] a pound and a half
each morning really I can't see that
close to my scales let that I can't see
that far away
Mangia electronic oh really you can like
the point all right you can wait drugs
or you can wait [ __ ] on it I try to I
try that way yeah I try to weigh how
much of [ __ ] each day and then I look at
it this little game I play with myself I
go I reckon that's a it's a point eight
of a pound [ __ ] that why not oh yeah
yeah yeah eyeball it almost like a guy
to Delhi
another thing I found a half a roast
beef right I guess you white got the
carnival oh my god well listen I want to
talk about I want to talk about a few
things with you today and one of the
things I really want to talk about
because I just revisited it you mean his
shits wasn't one of them without it I
wasn't on the top of my
he did answer the door in his underwear
which I thought was kind of strange he
goes I just got out of the shower and I
was like now you just did that for me
you wanted me to see the slim trim gym
yeah yeah and but I want to talk about
legit your show you had on FX
and I watched a show the other night and
it's there was two parters it was the
racist episode right step aside yeah and
that was one of the funniest things I've
ever seen in my life the fact that you
went all the way and dropped the N bomb
on television if you haven't seen it
it's on Netflix you can watch it season
two let's begin I think the first two
episodes are sick I think it's like
three I think two and three or three and
four one of them yeah and that was the
hardest one to get through and it
actually wasn't meant to be a two-part
episode but because we said the N word
we had to say to the network like they
said you can say it but we can bleep it
or we can is like I'm cable right and
then and they said if you say to be
continued like you're going to redeem
yourself right so that all the episodes
of two-parters all the episodes go
together
yeah but that one we had the right to be
continued so people thought oh it's not
over they're going to take it back
they're gonna apologize
[Laughter]
this sort of happened to me in real life
I dated a girl and I went on two dates
with it and I thought she was just the
best chick ever and she was fun and she
was funny and I was really into it and
then just in a public place on about the
third date she says the n-word like in
front of black people and everything and
looked at me like like rhyme i right am
i right am i right or am i right
she didn't say it like even ironically
or with a twinkle in the eye that a
drunk friend say something should you
you know in Australia the biggest
compliment you can call a person is a
digger the IgG yeah right because that's
what they call the army vets in World
War one they dug all the trenches and so
even now during Remembrance days they go
I use the great digger and you know so
if you got a good mate that you're
really down with your guide digger like
that right I I fell into that I made
friends with an Australian guy and I was
in London I was in Camden which is the
blackest area and drunk across a
courtyard
yelled out hey digger and then trying to
explain Australian history to a Jamaican
guy yeah it's yeah so explain any
history to Jamaican guys time so what it
was was just a episode about about about
that incident happen in my real life and
then where's where's the line what line
do you because we've all dated women who
let's say a bad cooks or bad drunks or a
bad how hot does the person have to be
before you go no that's too much right
go out with you because of this one
personality trait and so I was finding
my character in the second episode
started to like try to reason with it
then our Jackson comes along yeah well I
liked it I liked the funny thing is is
you had dinner with like you were gonna
get a date with her and you were afraid
to take her out into the real world cuz
you're afraid she was gonna say anything
see you order Chinese food and have it
delivered and then you you're like you
think you're in the clear you don't even
let the Mexican guy in and then she
notices in this she sits down she goes
only in LA you know a [ __ ] or you know
what you know a [ __ ] delivering cheap
food well the funny thing was we had we
had the girl who played at Betsy she was
about five foot tall just little tiny
blonde actress and and she came along to
audition and it the day that we had to
audition we were we were auditioning
another episode that involved Mexican
gang members so that the the lobby was
just filled with guys who were in gangs
they're all covered in tattoos it's like
it's a it's a great thing if you're ever
in a Mexican gang in LA yeah and you get
out this acting work to be had oh yeah
you've got the authentic tattoos and we
got the guys of Breaking Bad in the show
they were two of the the thugs in
Breaking Bad we're like brilliant yeah
we could have gotten the two twins off
Breaking Bad from that season oh wow
they're all out there if you need it and
it's the same thing like like do you
reckon like like Arabic
is when like a 911 happens they're like
I'm gonna get me so much acting work
yeah well law and order went that went
through a mine I know Mom I know my fall
was just like bring us another one
I know Maz Jobrani was busy as a
[ __ ] for a while man that guy
was working all the time playing every
terrorist there was yeah but you know
the cool thing is is like all this sorry
so every week we went we were Mexican
gangbanger type guy comes in and then we
had cute little innocent white girl
comes in and the doors are very thin
you've been to auditions where you can
oh it's here that other person
auditioning yeah I have untyped
somewhere I haven't edited together but
I have at least 30 hot women in
Hollywood saying the n-word splice it
together to make the most viral video
ever and sang it with gusto yeah way to
say it I mean you got it you got to
think I learn it you gotta own it yeah
on some level there's there's a bunch of
people that would love to be able to
like have the permission to go in and
just drop the n-bomb like you say with
gusto and like I'm getting paid for this
is why I'm doing it you know I'm doing
it for this well we did it we only have
you I still say the people that say it's
so great on camera can say it in the
normal life we did the film we did it we
did the shoot that she said it on Santa
Monica Pier and you know when you're
shooting and every homeless person walks
up what are you filming
yeah and they're always they always come
up because they want 50 but that's my
son crying back and say yeah but they
they want 50 back so they whatever they
want you know and they won't want to be
or they want to be in it you know and so
so we're on the pier there's there's
about 10 homeless black people fishing
of the end Wow
and were they fishing for we need you to
move out the way just to get out of this
scene
are you familiar ah nothing and then
bang she says it loudly yeah with people
with psychological problems right what
are you filming it in what jail actually
gives them a place to stay one of these
guys filming dango Unchained - oh my god
[Laughter]
Oh like all the stuff I remember like
because I you know I remember when you
used to do we did my show in Vegas and
you the story that your that your series
started on the pilot yeah most of the
stories in legit were based on some of
your personal experience yeah was a mom
was almost all but it was basically all
my stand-up routines sort of just played
out and then season 2 was just you know
there was there was things like the
beginning of season 2 that there's a
love interest to here's a girl who I met
in high school who who just stopped
talking to me I was like 15 16 I was
devastated you know madly in love at
that age and then years and years passed
and what happened was I saw the true
story I was I was like 15 I had sex with
this girl she'd come down to Sydney we
did something like acting like summer
camp you know right i shagged and she
went back at the prison and then we were
just in love and then I would bring her
and she probably doesn't know that I
changed my name to a state it's Samantha
crane Zwick if you're listening
we're actually big enough maybe someone
will pass it on oh there you go
there you go this could be your entrance
into Australian market but this go goes
is go
I used to ring her up from payphones
I'll put like a dollar in and that would
be like five seconds back in the day I
love you then you hear the quaint acute
that was my one call for the week and
I'd write to her every day and teenage
[ __ ] before the Internet oh yeah had to
get a pen and paper out there mail it
right wait by the mailbox for a [ __ ]
little heart with an arrow through it
you know yeah yeah smiley yes so I and
then just the letters just just stopped
and so I told my mom and dad that I was
I was going on to stay at a friend's
house and I got on a bus to Queensland
from Sydney to Brisbane which is a I'm
gonna say 16-hour bus right whoa it's
not like Greyhound are you really yeah
like it great I'm like really the worst
and I got on this bus got all the way up
there and then I brought flowers these
wilted flowers and I I walked all the
way to the door and knocked on the door
and then a father told me to [ __ ] off if
it was America he would have come out
with a shotgun in the top of the
environment right Wow so I got back on
the bus and sat there and cried for 16
hours back there as I gave anyway cut to
maybe I was 21 or something like that
and and I actually bumped into her I'm
gonna but you could really [ __ ] talk
to me you didn't tell me why you start
are still holding these grudge bounces
16 you know when I was 16 remnants and
she goes well I was pregnant and I had
to have an abortion right Oh
go knocked up right now wonder the calls
just stopped in the dead [ __ ] hated
me and I was like and that's the story
that I tell in the show is from this
moment I'm in the school is you had the
abortion that's why she stopped talking
and but then the girl goes in real life
she goes she goes look I'm pretty sure
it wasn't you I sing a few guys at that
time but you were the one that lived
furthest away so I told my dad it was
you that's like if your parents find
weed and you blame it on the guy that
never comes to your house I didn't put
that bit this story I thought I'll make
it more authentic like I did get a girl
looked up but like that's great like I
actually was seeing another guy I was
probably his I've seen a lot of guys
well you've done you're the one that
came first dad it happened at bed if Dan
Innis right into Sydney you know well
you've had you've done what now three
specials I've gotten three three four
America anyway I should say four four
four American television five a lot but
I did I did one one of the four in the
last five years I did in London but it
aired on Showtime sorry I sold Showtime
it was so I did my HBO special a sort of
God then I did alcohol accost in London
which wasn't originally called alcoholic
Coast it's just like a so [ __ ] drunk
like make it a theme yeah never I'll
never forget as long as I live the the
one of the funnest nights we ever had in
Vegas was you came you did the whole
weekend you did Thursday Friday Saturday
Thursday you came in you had a couple
beers before the show you went in you
did that we did one show Thursday had a
couple beers before the show Friday for
some reason you had a couple beers
nothing in between second show you had a
couple beers fine Saturday you came in
the first show you had a couple beers
you had eight drinks because I had to
sign the tab you had you stood at the
thing in you had like eight vodka tonic
or something or vodka cranberries at the
thing in the second show you were I've
never laughed so [ __ ] hard in my life
that's the problem with being a boozy
coming he's the best shows I've ever had
in my career of being legless but also
the worst there's no happy medium right
and whenever you're sober on stage I
always have good shows I never have
terrible shows writes over but I don't
think I ever get that little moment of I
love I love having a few pops I mean I
mean people tell me you're the only
comic that can drink a whole bottle
around the first you know and then be
fine for the second show to me it's
always am I always think if there's a
waitress crying I'm killing any time the
crowds on my level but yeah well you
know I don't handle booze as good as I
used to but I do and I do enjoy being
drunk of it but the last time I got
[ __ ] drunk was I was in Sydney and I
was doing the big theater like 2006 you
don't think two shows at the first show
killed and then like all these guys that
I went to school with who were probably
bullied me I didn't remember being
friends with they all showed up on our
back stays in the dressing room so I was
given everyone drinks I kept drinking
and everyone the room found me funny and
so but then as soon as I walked on the
stage I was like oh [ __ ] I'm pissed
like I'm super [ __ ] drunk and just
people write comments and stuff like it
was embarrassing outranking but anyway
the thing that sort of I couldn't
remember me jokes I was doing that weird
thing where where if you tell it you
tell a joke and you is because the
second show you're worried that you've
just told it twice and yeah I'm sure
yeah and there's a half way through you
have that look on your face like are
they not laughing cuz I told this one
already yeah and they're not gonna tell
you no Hanny klutzy but anyway my dad
was at the first show and he's at the
second show and I thought I came off I
thought oh my dad's gonna be so
disappointed me turns out he was so
[ __ ] drunk
[Laughter]
you seem like four shows that week he's
like you mixed it up in that one
well I you had the show you did you were
I mean you were pretty you were fine I
mean as far as like you did you didn't
do the show work for but at the end you
told the story that was the pilot for
legit yeah I told that story
and it was like in and it was so funny
because they oh they're all the
waitresses are trying to get out of
there
the second show it's like one it was
like one o'clock errs have been you went
to like 1:45 it was like a two and a
half hour show and I pissed myself
so [ __ ] hard I you've just told me
I've wasted some waitresses time that's
a [ __ ] them I could care less about
their still I was in the palms right yes
you still yeah no I haven't done Vegas
in like three years well you came over
when we did when we over at the Paris
you came over and did the podcast there
you guys came over with you when you
were still doing the podcast I I now do
the the joint at the Hard Rock and the
last time I did this there's several
stories that go along with this this
this is this is what what drugs'll do
this three different versions of this
story I've heard from the three
different people that were they Jason
Hill might it was their forest sure was
there and and me and Sam kink in my tool
manager and I did the joint and they
come out to me and they're like they're
like yeah the show starts at 8:00 and
they go you gotta be done by 9:30 people
spent like people spend more money in
Vegas the tickets like 60 bucks nineteen
I think it's like forty right yeah I
said I've got to support except what two
guys out with me so he could go out
afterwards I go they're gonna do like
ten minutes each but I got to do at
least hour and a half myself people
playing 60 bucks I can't just give him
an hour right and then we there's a band
on after you you have to be out of the
venue by 9:30 the band starts at 11:00 I
said like because I remember getting in
trouble with you cuz I did your and Joey
McIntyre
yeah well we didn't give a [ __ ] about
him we just we just went out we just
went lamb
fifteen minutes and then the owner the
palms came and yelled at me because Joey
McIntyre had to do some lounge singing
from your New Kids on the Block
no I one of them are loops he was from
New Kids on the Block you know no the
owners are the Malone right right you
want someone to manager or something up
claim up and yelled at me goes ten
minutes over and then afterwards I was
drunk in there was maybe ten people came
to see Joey McIntyre yeah [ __ ] you oh
yeah yeah we never I never listen to
that I I said [ __ ] it we're just do what
we do
I had a little chip on my shoulder about
Vegas people kicking me out of rooms I
guess and and and then so I always I
think you have to be off there's a bank
coming on 11:00 I think I literally said
look who gives a [ __ ] some late-night
[ __ ] bands coming on at 11:00 right
and they go it's Guns and Roses and I
went yeah because I'd saw like two
thousand tickets in there they're gonna
sell like 8000 standing they gonna get
rid of all the chairs so I better get
off this comes and Rises but so I go you
know acts will be late by an hour anyway
I'm on stage I'm on stage and I [ __ ]
I I'm doing a rap but I'm trying to get
off my 9:30 I know I can get off at 9:45
no one's gonna get too angry and I'm
trying to act like the show's running
longer than it is for the audience I'm
going flying I'm on stage going look
I've been on for too long I've got to
get off the bed look I'll give you
another 10 minutes even though I knew I
start 10 minutes left
yeah you know these little tricks and
then I said something to the effective
ah [ __ ] it I'm the Axl Rose I've never
yeah accident it's not like Axl Rose has
ever left me waiting for a gig right I
said something stupid like that cut to I
get off stage and I take a handful of
mushrooms someone brought a bag of
mushroom like how the story starts out
there he goes and I come on stage and I
need a handful of mushrooms yeah you
know this story is gonna get nothing but
better if I didn't tell you my shoes
forever there's all these people address
I'll take a handful of mushrooms and
there was and I can't say who it is but
there was a professional athlete up
there as well with drugs
it would just been knocked out of his
respective playoff career you know
here's the theme of just you know he was
[ __ ] right huh
anyway so so we're hanging out with this
athlete and the anything and then I go
down and I do photos after the show and
maybe out of the 2,000 people I reckon
500 people stayed which is more than
most normally 200 people stay for photos
yeah 500 a lot yeah and funny and then
at about a hundred and fifty people mark
the mushrooms kick in he's got my arm
around strangers one stranger after the
night yeah are you freaking out a little
Rica now it's the only time I just
walked away from the photos like and
people probably just I think I'm a jerk
there was things online about what a
jerk I was that night but it was I was
[ __ ] it was like lizards with every
phone I must just be making oh no those
are those are creepy I when I told
Lampanelli a lot she gets a ton of those
and there's just so many people that you
know there's just creepy people and
every group of people know a ton of
people coming up yeah it's like I mean
you know I mean cuz you know when that's
when it's just me or are they all
interpreter we it's our fans but you
know her there's just she has thousands
of fans so just from all walks of life
and you just get wigged out well I think
it's like it's a weird thing to have to
stand in that line and take tons and
tons of pictures because it's like the
first five or ten okay but it's yeah
it's like being Santa Claus and you're
standing there and it's the same thing
and they all want to talk to you and
they all want to tell you so devalued
now though I think before when it was
like okay you had to bring your camera
you had to really be a fan you have to
really be into it to do it now it's just
like it's the same as here's a picture
of my Sunday I ate at Denny's and then
oh yeah you know it's like it's not
equal you know what I mean because
everybody's a little phone it's like
this it's just everything's right there
all the time everyone's taking a picture
of everything now ha ha I made a cake
from Australia though just finish this
very quickly yes so so we I get all
wasted I'm down standing in the bar and
we go in and we watch Guns & Roses so we
watch the whole concert and then they
invite us up for a gig I'm for an
after-party and it's like it's at the
top of the the the Hard Rock and it's
like a strip of Paul's and there's
[ __ ] it's just the slots eat each
other happened it was like a weirdest
thing and I'm on mushrooms I can't even
talk to me yeah I'm like wallpaper I'm
just anger like trying to make
conversation and then I'm staying there
and then the security guy goes mr. Rose
wants to talk to you and now I'm like
trying to chat into Axl Rose I've been a
big fan for many years and he goes I not
a lot of people know but I'm actually a
really big comedy fan and I enjoyed your
show this evening but it's being
completely overblown about how many
times I showed up late for gigs and I
got a photo with him in the two of us
you can tell that I'm [ __ ] wide and
he's just he doesn't usually take photos
take photos no no one else's the party
got a photo with him Wow yeah and and
and the weird thing is is this is how
when I show people the photo that guy
that's not him it's like because we all
remember him from 20 years ago right and
so no one's seen him age and people go
oh he's got no money it's like jumping
for 20 years it's been 30 years right
Wow since the pake yeah oh yeah okay
about what math yeah but is the things
we see we see slash appears everywhere
right I I will say this though I saw
regular Guns and Roses he was he was -
not a regular obviously
regular but I mean his version the guns
and roses and he was like two hours late
but it made my whole night because we
were late from like I did my show and
then and then and then I guess uh cuz we
work at the was headlining the punchline
they couldn't work it to you though you
could you know go to the Warfield and we
know the manager there so we're like I
willing for Jimmy and he comes from
because oh my god it's a zoo two hours
late okay okay miss anything literally
saw my old roommate Jenny gave me two
huge sudden you hear lights go down he
was incredible because we really slashes
we would say slash is greater than but
it's the voice that's guns and roads
that's the guy loved slash she's amazing
but any great guitar player can sound
like slash no one sounds like they
didn't miss a beat I thought it was the
I saw him in 92 and I think he would
perform better our mushrooms sure yeah
but his voice was mint yeah I see I saw
I saw him when they were when they were
starting at their peak right at the end
I saw him the open for the stones and
that's when they started that was kind
of one of their last shows they played
as a band together and that his main is
a band together what the first original
Guns N'Roses
what's supporting the stones that were
bigger than the stones at their peak no
but yeah but they played they they
opened they opened at the Coliseum it
was the calcium as the it was living
color Guns and Roses in the rolling
Colin's I was a thing right yeah the
stones are different like the stones had
ac/dc open form yeah those had Pearl Jam
open form the stones are the funniest
thing is rush was like if they did some
free show in Canada for like two million
people and rush thought that they would
like beat before he's after ac/dc and
mixed like Eileen kinda well yeah but
Mick was like it's ac/dc
yeah but Slayer can't follow [ __ ] two
hours of a CDs no no one has a better
than a CD no I and that's it's it's the
best because I love Australian people in
town you always perform before that's
the first thing I say you know so yeah
greats been the rose from Australia and
then
even like ten-year-old chipped and even
like what age 18 year old chicks are
like ac/dc I'm like God it's a bit of a
fallacy that their Australian because
they are and they aren't it's they
started out in Australia their
quintessentially in Australian rock
bands they started out the pub scene
around Perth but though there were
Scottish immigrants and then also the
lead singer now is from Newcastle
England right and Bon Scott had a but
this is like a statue of Bon Scott in
Fremantle right like in Australia but it
was like my brother lives on the highway
to hell the caning highway which is the
the highway they reference because they
used to drive to this bar that and then
the [ __ ] is gig in town and that's where
they wrote the song well that's my way
to the top if you want a rocker because
it has everything about comedy they're
getting ripped off underpaid and I just
always played on every road trip and but
everyone's gonna say now oh the long
with it I was gonna say the money you
like the drama just [ __ ] trying to
kill a guy dirty deeds done dirt cheap I
think they live it I like that so much
better than like well now he owns a
vegan health standing cells you know a
fresh few juices now he's on with myth
and ordering a hit on someone I think I
think anybody our age has got to have
had like that experience with ac/dc
that's like one of the greatest bands I
remember we used to say yeah I took a
picture of it in the in like the Des
Moines Airport I took it on like this
honor I got that I got the premium one
with the lower level will play it
afterwards oh that's a that's yeah I
mean the my my son's favorite song is
thunderstruck yeah he's 92 and that's
because it's in the movie planes oh [ __ ]
we used to sit me and my buddy Robbie
gives him he had a 67 Chevelle
that had no back seat he put speakers in
it like home speakers I put it back of
it and we used to drive in and this was
back in the early 80s and you pot was
way illegal in Oklahoma we used to pull
into a car wash at night you know in one
of the bays so we'd hide out from
everywhere and just smoke out and ac/dc
just blaring as loud as possible and it
looked like like the inside of the car
was on fire yeah I mean it was just
small build
they made me I made it through Catholic
school because of ac/dc I mean like I
said they're the best band when I was
ten the best band when I was twenty yeah
that's been like Pig and they've never
made a ballad they've never ever done
anything other than just kick ass I mean
that's the Grammys this year that were
the best at oh yeah and just these
little things like now in the show
everyone gets devil horns
you can address your kid this summer is
Angus what you see now everyone dresses
their kid is Angus for uh well III my
kid I think he's just about to hit this
year for Halloween when he gets to
choose his own outfit okay you know the
first couple of years just used
something into a family motif yeah I was
leading my kid Angus if it came out a
boy my wife was told yeah we were gonna
do it like because there's only there's
no Angus my son is named after my
girlfriend's father who is actually
called Henricus who was a Dutch guy
right and so everyone called him Hank
when he moved to Canada and I I said
it's not like named Hank Jeffries is a
cool name right yeah and but my mother
just has such a pain in the ass she goes
I will not call him that name it's too
common now let me say something
I grew up extraordinarily common and
poor my mother has jimick Jim and
exquisite name in Australia
hi respiration Jim James respiration she
goes Hank who's good you know what it
was she doesn't like it because it's a
very American name is what she doesn't
like because there's no Australian Hanks
yeah Hank Hank is like a real like
country-western yeah Hank Williams jr.
yeah yeah like that type of thing right
there's no Australian Hanks we don't use
that name right and and sorry I said we
you will that's what you're [ __ ]
calling him because that would be
[ __ ] name yeah you can make up
another one if you want but he won't
answer to it cause you anything but Hank
Tartu piss off it's I wouldn't call
divided or I would call a Sydney I would
have you know after the city I grew up
in but also not Sydney Crosby because I
assume any my children would come out
black because I don't trust my
girlfriend well let's talk about that
you you I mean how old's your son now
he's he's birthday's November so he's
two in a bit two in a heart more than
two it's the birthday I'm November 12th
6/6 that's my mom's birthday November
12th there's a lot of people born on
over I don't like a whole month
a lot of people born in November yeah no
but a lot of people are whatever that
nine months is before that is no it's
only because you notice it because
you're born in November so you take note
when other people are born November you
go I'm gonna Valentine's Day I feel like
everyone's born on Valentine's Day
because I know all the famous people who
are born well there you go
maybe I do I do know a lot of people
born like within two days of me yeah
well it's strange that there's a lot of
you made a lot of when you make other
kids the same age as my son you you meet
like oh you born a week apart
Hank's a great name though I mean I
called everyone named Henry Hank cuz I
just like I like the name Hank but Hank
is like not gonna hopefully take over
like like I named my daughter Isabella
thinking like Isabella such a nice name
it means like Queen in Italian hey thank
you now Isabelle
like [ __ ] Jennifer you know now
there's like everyone's named Isabella
about now she's now she's called Ella
half the time because there's five
Isabella's and she likes Ella but I'm
like just up named is he is he's like a
TSA lesbian yeah well the Australian the
Australian is he is idea I think you're
named a key though
oh is it a key yeah looks like though
but but I got interviewed I was in
Australia and they said how famous are
you in America and I'm like I don't know
if you know stand-up comedy I guess you
know it's like it's a Canty question but
it's kind of a kunti question because
then the thing is cuz then if you go
really fight you sound like a prick or
if you go not famous at all what am i
selling here I don't know what I'm meant
to be doing in your interview and then
she went through Australians who are
allegedly famous in America and she goes
I want you to answer you more or less
famous than these people
what the [ __ ] on it who is this from
Australia haven't made it over here I go
I get some more famous in there yeah I
guess and then she mentioned like an
athlete that's trying to be in the NFL
that I'd never heard of and I go well I
you know I guess I'm more famous than
him in the comedy world but less in the
sporting world I guess then it was and
then it was like easy Ori years earlier
and I'd never heard of her at this stage
and I said I guess I'm a favor snake has
never heard of her and then she went
well she has this many gold albums and
two million Twitter followers so you're
saying you're more famous think she
makes shitty music maybe that's why I've
never heard of her yeah maybe that's why
I'm not down yeah I mean literally like
ac/dc is probably the only band I knew
on the Grammys when you said about it
like I thought it was a miracle cos
hockey was on that night and that was
like it was over they were done at 8:05
it was like now I can get back to my
life I'd have to sit there and
fast-forward through everybody well I
never watched watch the Grammys and
stuff like that you used to watch him
and think I wonder you but it used to be
kind of like it used to be somewhat
interesting
now it's like there's I mean they you
know I think they look like Barbra
Streisand and Neil Diamond doing in
Jewett moments right but also we have
[Music]
more but also it was all no there's no
there's no musicians there's no
musicians yes it's all people are
chronic yeah it's alright
it's geography as well it's a lot of
dancing yeah there's also a lot of voice
it like there's not their real voice
it's gone through a voice a voice out
you know kind of all changer but it's
not bands it's not people but that's oh
my daughter she plays trumpet now she's
playing drums she wants to be like some
be famous it's like we have to learn how
to to write your own songs of playing
instrument cuz all the other girls
they're just strippers yeah I mean like
what's it what's his name money yeah I
mean I mean like be Beyonce
she's a stripper who married a crack
dealer that's like that's what she is
she just danced well I'd like to
distance myself from those comments
you're gonna distance yourself from any
dancer I mean that's what I would to me
because I'm people like well well like
oh that's you know like or they think
I'm like oh that's racist are they ever
black people here but I go no they're
like oh no strippers like no I don't
call like Mariah Carey a stripper she
sings like you know people that sing
that have a talent that's so much
different than being notification here's
one
what are you cold in the
is that bird off the voice is the
popular bird the Christina Aguilera
she's pretty much her or she can sing
that go yeah she doesn't dance like the
dancing she brought up that gotta get
nasty video what is it called naughty or
whatever it was yes she had some pretty
good dirty yeah well I said the chaps in
the boxing ring thank you that was nice
that was over 10 years ago but it
probably looks very tiny but it yeah but
that was the most outrageous thing on it
like as someone who's raising a girl
when you're like she wants when you see
role models literally it's like you know
it's like you don't want Beyonce in the
same breath as mrs. Obama you mean like
it wasn't I don't want that to be the
say like that shouldn't be like you
don't want to grow up to be here like
she's she's a well I think the biggest
the biggest one was like the Miley Cyrus
now I mean this chick is such as she
gave a great speech for Joan Jett though
oh did she actually thinks she's Maude
Lee talented cheap Miley Cyrus yep
personally I think she's got an
incredibly cute ass and it's I mean
she's only but she's old enough now I
can say that ohyou years ago I couldn't
say that but you used to think country
no try in Britain wish you had to have
sex with 16 year olds go for your life
but not over here with your restrictive
laws yeah
well that's what's fine about now my
daughter is old enough to like before
she's watch the kid shows but now she
watches like the teenage shows like
victorious justice the chicken the
Family Guy they said like Nickelodeon
they add funicula letting the good
Nickelodeon ask your daughter discreetly
who that girl on the screen is then take
her laptop into the bathroom
what's his family guy constantly through
she loves I like how that's her sense of
humor yeah is like Family Guy know that
I think the funniest TV that's different
now is the kids who got their own I grew
up watching four channels and you guys
would have had cable way before
Australia like we only got cable like 10
years ago or something we had four
channels and
on those four channels that was all
you'd watch and there's one TV so I used
to I I seen every Apple in castel I'm
still a movie and and all Atmaram pot
kettle films I've seen all I've seen up
gallon or maybe Shirley Temple film I
saw these because my mother used to
watch shitty black-and-white movies on a
Sunday and that was the only movie that
was on and now kids today and I used to
watch the same sitcom with my parents
watch but now they have their own
channels where they just watch their own
shitty [ __ ] television yeah yeah no
yeah they don't used to be there let me
be six channels before cable like the
three and then PBS then like two or
three ones you're like 53 now and uh and
that was but that was it though you what
like only Saturday mornings were you
watching what my grandfather don't you I
always watched my grandfather my
grandfather said what was on you didn't
say oh no I wouldn't watch this show
like that's somewhat robot don't you
think now but don't you think now the
raciest shows of them all are the
cartoons because they can get away with
so much more of course of course Ken I'd
like Family Guy had a thing where the
the baby the baby's learning how to swim
and he wants to be a faster swimmer so
the dog walks in on him and and the
Stewie is there shaving like his whole
body and he turns to the dog and he goes
you know feel free to say no to this but
would you shave my coin purse shave my
balls
what Seinfeld was saying that comedies
getting people are getting too offended
too easily by stand-up comedy yeah now
my point on this is why is it asked
comedians that get in trouble and not
comedy programming or comedy acting what
why do comedians if we if I say rape
joke onstage why am I the worst person
in the world and man say in Australia I
got a lot of flack on the last tour and
people protesting articles I got they
sent they sent the aged newspaper which
is one of the biggest newspaper sent a
woman to review my show who runs a
battered woman's refuge it doesn't sound
like she's a comedy reviewer why is that
fit and all because I did a Bill Cosby
rape joke
in the whole thing now really a joke my
fights like The Improv them like that
joke is hilarious well my point is this
why am i more responsible then the
family guy makes rape jokes monty
python's the life of brian has a rape
joke throughout the whole thing about
his mum being raped by a Roman and then
in the end she goes oh I I was raped at
first implying that she started to enjoy
right why is it as comedians that told
we can't do something or marginalize or
censored when okay so first of all first
of all why you'll have to do comedy in
cartoon form or in movie form and then
why is comedy censored and not drama
why can you make why can't you make a
rape joke which is still a part of
fiction but you can depict the rape
scene why is the drama more important
than a joke I don't I see I completely
agree with you and I think that it the
country and it's not the whole country I
think what happens is you have these
small groups that that are offended by
anything it wouldn't matter what the
[ __ ] you said they just they just don't
like your point of view so they're gonna
find something in your act to pick out
to say this person is this kind of this
kind of person I I have to say though
like and I think Jim's out there the
furthest and probably the most famous
person that says whatever but I think by
me just being a comic that says whatever
and I'm on PC way more people come up
and take notice of me you know I mean I
think that plays to like if you're
willing to go out there and not in that
and not to say something that isn't
funny I needed to say to make it in a
funny way I think then you stand out
because people wow you know you're
saying that people it's like yeah I mean
it a lot of the women and I would think
would be totally like well I always
think the women who like themselves love
me women who hate themselves they hate
me but I mean just people you wouldn't
think like they're the ones are like wow
that's amazing cuz they they're yearning
for someone to break through but I also
reached the age of double-edged sword
you take the good with the bad
like obviously I'm never gonna win any
major awards or anything
because it'll always be someone on
whatever panel it doesn't like what I do
and then that'll always and that's been
throughout my career right but that's
the way I get noticed they get it and
then hopefully you get on you get an HBO
special on Netflix or something like
that no one blocks you along the way
because hopefully there's enough
rational minded people to to make it a
right but what I from is is a Seinfeld
says says college students are getting
to offend it Seinfeld is arguably one of
the least offensive comics on the planet
doesn't even swear that's what makes it
great that he came out against these
people who have been there's people a
woman wrote an article in The Huffington
Post angry about what Seinfeld said she
was offended by him saying people get
too offended stupid yeah offended by
those comments cuz I was at college and
I you're saying that we all get offended
when you're doing it right now right
right now you're saying that you're
offended by saying that why we said I'm
saying you get offended too quickly III
just dis can't you turned away I mean
when I was a kid it was always sticks
and stones can break your bones but
names will never hurt you and this
country got away from that now it's like
oh my god you're called was like it's
like everything is like a hate it's like
a hate speech or it's a bullying
cyberbullying yeah yeah and all this
[ __ ] but so I think but but the thing
that used to bully me all the time that
was a kid he comes out and buys me
dinner once a year cuz it comes the
Breeders Cup like we're great friends
purpose these are all nice to me I mean
like I mean I was picked all the time
he's just stutter you know I you picked
on constantly it made me a better person
see the thing that bugs me the most
about what you're talking about the
offensive thing is like you're making a
joke about Bill Cosby the Bill Cosby
rate joke
Bill Cosby's the one that raped chicks
you're not rated your yes Einstein's I
go I go I did a tour on theatres editor
in theaters and I did these two gigs in
Canada and two days before me Bill Cosby
was performing and he's performing this
was just after the rape allegations came
in he saw two thousand seats in both
theaters and only a thousand people
showed up and if the other people showed
up didn't show up because they're not
gonna watch a rapist for two hours even
though they bought
for a thousand people Wayne type of
money yeah giving a refund the same
people walk out of my shows because of
the things that I'm saying because they
wanted to watch a good clean wholesome
coming like Bill Cosby who rapes rather
than watch a dirty comic like myself she
was half away but see it's like it's
like you say anything anymore like I do
a joke about the Pope about the Pope you
know condoning spanking kids and I say
who's different than all the other posts
before the condone [ __ ] kids yeah and
it's like and and it's funny be and it's
I think it's a funny joke I don't give a
[ __ ] what anybody else thinks I like it
because it's it's true it's true it's
true there's a I mean and it's like
people kind of sit there for a second
they go oh yeah that's actually true cuz
there's I mean there's it's known the
Catholic Church has millions of dollars
put away just to shut just to pay off
the people those great offended I've
only been offended like one time by what
anyone's ever said on stage and it was
just this year I was at a show in the
valley and this guy did a Bill Cosby
imitation and he didn't do a rape joke
[Laughter]
you're such a lazy [ __ ] hack that
you're gonna do a Bill Cosby imitation
and do pudding pop jokes yeah yeah you
piece of [ __ ] every now and again you
get offended every now and again someone
say something then what move on with
your life
but I think I think Bertha anypercent it
best when he said it when he was talking
about people that do this and he was
talking what bill said and I really
appreciate it it was was that it's like
I'm it's I'm buck
I'm a comedian I'm making a joke it's
just a joke it's not I'm not out there
trying to you know it's just it's just a
[ __ ] joke oh no it's not a TED talk
you can't yeah yeah this isn't if you
said it in an interview and you said it
seriously and you said these are my
beliefs or whatever like that but
[ __ ] omen III [ __ ] about my own
life on stage like like I start with
this story
embellish it and by the end of the time
I'm going to stage I'm telling the story
I'm like I'm [ __ ] just lying now
[Laughter]
three foot if I get asked in a in an
interview I'll tell you the truth but on
stage if I can show you what should I
show you how did you start on stage
because I met a guy from Australia last
night who was who said I gotta get
Australian to do some festivals over
there but but he said just now it's
starting where there's like a little
scene local scenes now yeah there was
one comedy club in Sydney and I used to
which is you know for half million
people in the city it should have more
you know but I I used to go down there
and try to do the open mic night and I
started in Perth actually and they had
an open mic night on a Wednesday well
they didn't even have it they do
commenting on a Wednesday where they put
one guy in the middle who's was these
first time you know yeah and and so I
used to go down and the waiting list was
like three months there's more people
wanting to do comedy then actually
wanting to watch it and so I lied I just
[ __ ] lied my teeth I said I've been
doing it for years I just moved over
from Sydney and I was a professional for
the infinite no one checked anything HBO
special tonight he's going to be running
some new material ready and and I I got
up and did I did alright remember your
first joke you ever wrote first big sort
of set piece alright was a religious
joke about it's still not a bad joke if
you put it in there if you bookend it
with better jokes see I I was always on
this is how the joy came about I was on
ecstasy in college and I was sitting and
I'd burnt through the night and my
friends would have left when I was
sitting in my house my apartment
and on the TV I started watching there
was only four channels in Australia
still and I'm watching [ __ ] religious
television so I'm watching like good
more like the Sunday prayers and on top
of [ __ ] and then I never realized
until then that Jesus didn't do any God
activities until he was thirty and he
died at 33 yeah and what the [ __ ] like
his mum was artificially inseminated by
an angel he obviously knew like someone
must have whispered it easier that he
was God along the way and why did he
work as a carpenter until he was 30 and
I said well maybe it's not his fault
maybe he's dad set him down when he was
young and said look Jesus I know being
God's awesome and all that but maybe you
should get yourself a career first yeah
yourself a trade you'll always have that
to fall back on - and if this you know
it's alright yeah shitty religious joke
yeah
and I I think at that stage had probably
been watching a lot of you know or
watching there's a guy could Anthony
Morgan I used to watch a lot in
Australia and then I think I started
watching Richard Pryor and concert at
that stage and yeah you know III didn't
get good at common erican for four years
I was I was making a living after year
but I didn't get good at it for these
four years and then I think I said I
think every year I think I've gotten
worse at it and then I bring out a
special I go it's alright I mean it's
amazing it's amazing to me how I mean
like you I know you are from Austria you
were told you were to luck you went to
England as soon as I finished University
I went straight to England for 10 years
because I just I was I was in England
from 23 till about 33 and I did comedy
in Australia a year before that and and
the cool thing is England's the opposite
of Australians there's more people
wanting to watch comedy then you can
perform it you know at least at that
stage did you do any of those did you do
any of those like the pubs and the stuff
like that the mirth the mirth to her so
I got to do that last year oh yeah I'd
like Maidstone I did the Maidstone pub I
did that with Camilla Cleese no no come
in a class but who did you hook that
through some mercy some guys control
Yammer Jeff whiting yes
I've got a gig for you yeah for money to
come yeah but I remember earlier that
the big one around the corner Jeff yeah
this one yeah I remember we took this
train out to this town called Maidstone
where there's a big prison
yeah yeah yeah we and you go on this pub
they've been doing comedy there for like
30 years yeah and you're going in it's
just a little bitty pub there's dogs and
cats and [ __ ] in the pub and they in and
all of a sudden they go eight o'clock
everyone sits down grabs a beer hangs
out and [ __ ] watches comedy it's like
it was a great a great game the whole
the whole country's built for comedy
it's raining slightly raining outside
yeah yeah everyone wants that everyone's
house is too small to live in so they go
down to the park like the real thing in
England is the whole idea behind the
corner pub like the low every every end
of each street at the pub because
they're all given these shitty
apartments and they use the pub like
their living room oh wow that's like
this sort of a mentality where you go
down even if you're just having one
drink and then it's it's that whole let
Billy Joel Eric they're sharing a drink
they called loneliness but it's better
than drinking alone it's like these
people are all alone together know each
other they're not friends right you know
kind of like New York yeah inside it so
it does lend itself to having a comedy
gig in every problem some night and
there's always a quiz night on a Monday
and comedy on a Wednesday yeah but it's
fun you go around to these little
different pubs where you don't you
wouldn't normally like in America it's
like there's comedy club there's a set
up kind of comedy club in every city and
now in Irish bars Irish bars always have
comedy shows yeah but this but you know
the cool thing about there is you go to
this place it's like 300 years old or
400 years old it's a pub that you doing
come in 250 people who shot ya little
gigs you know and they paint it 200
pounds we'll say you like or you know
like and you only have to do it you only
have to do like 20 minutes 20 minutes
and there's an interval in between yeah
and then afterwards this is the weird
thing if you want to get [ __ ] out of
comedy through England
Britain is the only way to do it because
after the gig finishes everyone hangs
around still drinks till 2:00 in the
morning in the same room that you just
performed in even
comedy clubs in Britain they go and
after the show will be moving all the
tables and seats away and this will
become a nightclub and so you're in a
nightclub where you're the most famous
person even though you're brokers
[ __ ] you and a hundred dollars right
and you have a dressing room for
[ __ ] just off to the side but but
but but now you probably can't but you
came over here in a better position why
can't I when I came up here when I went
my comedy career those were like the
worst gigs the ones were like okay
comedy from 8:00 to 9:30 and then
there's gonna be disco so that means all
the local [ __ ] come at nine o'clock
and ruined your show by nine-thirty them
just trying to keep the people oh yeah
oh you think you know what I'm saying
though I did saw all those gifts I don't
envy anybody having to start comedy in
America it sounds [ __ ] I didn't just the
[ __ ] no one getting paid and also I
believe that this industry's carrier
over here than it is in Britain because
of the it's it's the US and them I'm
saying see in Britain you go into a gig
that's everyone's getting 150 pounds you
get out of 50 pounds I can have a favor
we all get a hundred fifty pounds and
then we all go drinking and we all buy
rounds because we all want the same
money and it is a comrade type of stuff
where comedy clubs over here it's like
that guys getting $25,000 and you're
getting $20 there's gotta be bitterness
seeing Britain if you get out of that if
you get above the [ __ ] the comedy clubs
don't advertise
who's on they might say ah tonight we
got these three names but it isn't like
you have to do radio for that Club
people just show up to the club
regardless of who's on so if you get so
popular that you believe people are
coming to see you and not the club and
you booked yourself a theater or you
booked yourself like there's a lot of
community centres with like a little 300
200 seat theaters mm-hmm you know booked
yourself one of those shitty little
artiste theaters and see if people show
up just to watch you yeah otherwise
you'll getting 170 bucks like the other
guys [ __ ] getting and the cool thing
to there is what I noticed is they have
they they call the emcee what do they
call the emcee the Olympic yeah yeah
that guy is usually the most experienced
guy that's guy that's actually been
doing it longer whereas in America
the emcee is a guy who's usually been
doing it uh you know maybe a year or two
and it's like he goes up and does five
minutes and kind of eats a little bit of
[ __ ] and then I tell you what like these
little phrasing things that a difference
so you know opening act I call opening
acts support acts right ya know you
never come support acts over here they
do one theater tours yeah it's like
forest is your support yes support but I
I rank I rang up Sam Morrell and I was
doing a gig in New York I was doing like
the Best Buy and I say hey lucky it come
down and support me he's like are you
okay mate I need a support for that
night okay yeah you know I'm gonna are
you gonna put my name on the guest list
or do I need to buy a ticket like I'd
love to see you Jim but uh if you put me
on the list I mean it's very nice
Forrest is my support act on the road
and you know a couple of reasons so and
I keep me nice thing because I got a
kidney I said I want to cheat or
anything like that so so but also
because I like the company I share a
room like Bert nerdy
yeah cuz you wanna know the differences
you know when you get drunk and you wake
up next to a girl that you're dating
your wife or your girlfriend or whatever
and you wake up in this fear you wake up
like if they're going to be angry at you
like you look over like
they're gonna be like good morning you
were drunk last night and so you wake up
a little bit fearful when you get drunk
and then you wake up next to your friend
it's just you just got it you just check
and make sure you got all your clothes
on so you laugh about the noise
yeah so this forest doesn't snore that
bad he does it far as dice no because
I'm like legendarily horrible snore
well hey he's uh he's going for first
girl like farces overweight oh I didn't
think I'm saying anything mean he's not
that overweight though what medical
science says well compared to la Kip her
dad in LA he's fat
yeah and in Houston he's James in season
two of well I remember when force was
still living in Florida and he used to
work with him yeah he's put on a few
pounds since then yeah we all have yeah
but the thing is he's got a lovely
girlfriend Lisa who's also a comedian
and Lisa just adores him I've never seen
a woman adore a man more than he's
girlfriend adores him and give it time
yet no she loved me too Jim the site is
like forested cone and she came over
here and she goes on your big television
Jim just his eyes sparkle so much time
like I can't see but she says she says
sleeping next to him ace is this big
snoring machine it's like sleeping next
to a majestic beast like like a lion
who's in the in the Africa just sleeping
near its prey it must make her feel safe
because I knew a chick that loved my
snoring because she's like it reminded
me you're robbing her of her dad oh
that's right we made her feel like a kid
again you enjoyed my fingering
on that note listen I know you got to
get to a meeting
but I want to thank you for being here
out where obviously they can follow you
on when does this go out we're probably
put out tomorrow
well I'll be in Indiana on Thursday
Friday I'm gonna be in to try go in
Detroit on Thursday Friday Indiana and
then I'll be doing there's still a
thousand tickets left but I'll be the
Hyde Park Festival in London Oh
fantastic
yeah check this front line it right the
lineup goes One Nights Kylie Minogue
then it's like Taylor Swift then blur
then the who and then the next night
Smee awesome you're cool about how about
that the who and then Jim Jefferies yeah
yeah well it's what they do is they do
they do Thursday to Sunday big bands
standing so 15,000 people and then they
do comedy monday to wednesday with
bigger acts and then it's like 5,000
seated yeah so who else is doing who
else is doing comedy Ed Burns doing a
night out Oh
Arlo Hanlon I believe is that which is
you'd have to be pretty she's the guy
that out of father Ted okay a popular
show every day rich holes doing an art
with his band he's quite popular he was
Romero you know what yeah you caught
this it rituals been living in London
for a number of years yeah he's very
popular yeah yeah I don't know that make
this too much longer but I know what's
the there's there's a sitcom that was
called how not to live your life know
what I'm talking about yeah I loved it
was on like whatever some cables are
throws a funny show on television
it's basically until the legit came out
but that guy that guy stand-up obviously
that show was hilarious you know what
I'm talking about though Stephen
American I don't know the British on
let's live your life
what's our name maybe okay the thing is
I always go with legit ago I was
cancelled so early I still did twice as
many episodes as Fawlty Towers in the
British office there you go we did 26
episodes only did 12 yeah you live your
life was like had maybe four seasons it
was so hilarious but uh I
whatever weird is they they just sell
this whole idea of just anything that
Britain makes they make again it's
gotten it's gone so far now that they're
reselling [ __ ] to you like there was
there was friends so Australia so
Britain made a show called coupling
where they took friends my British
friends they got couples or coupling
them and you know the they don't have
their own Jennifer Aniston do they know
so there's buying their own [ __ ] back
again oh Jesus then it's like what's
that is that documentary on CNN call the
70s yeah what's that the best that the
60s last year okay you know eight years
like it everything like this the TV in
the 70s then like whatever Wars we had
and then you know that's when I grew up
was that's what I was like my childhood
was the 70s really good check out check
out scene in the 70s is on demand it's
really good
I will okay and they then they had
Norman Lee then and know I know Norman
Lee strangely enough I I'm kind of
friends with Norman Lear in a weird way
he like legit but my girlfriend's
friends with him because anyway he's
like the grandfather of all my all you
know all the family one of the greatest
shows it's all in the family The
Jeffersons Maude good times
every great show in the seventh word and
Sun yeah even then in the eighties yet
the facts in life was his really Wow as
I but some Norman Lear was was hands
down that was like you know it's kind of
funny because like what's his name now
Steve Levitan Levitan has like modern
family and he had he's got a bunch of
shows kind of like this guy was Gloria
Chuck Lorre Chuck Lorre who's got you
know I mean like I never was a big fan
of two and a Half Men I never watched it
it was never my thing yeah but you know
who it's for it's not for you yeah but
it but he does have this other show this
the one about all the geeks the
scientist geeks yeah the Big Bang and
and I kind of watch that it's coming on
reruns now and it's actually pretty
goddamn funny yeah yeah it's funny full
character it's funny for carmine a nice
[ __ ] love it yeah and they're like 13
and 15 and I'm like alright well you
know yeah I kind of grown to like a link
but say this is the thing with Norman
Lear in the whole Archie but Archie
Bunker I eat invent that it was that was
the British Oh
till death do us part Wow and the
character was Alf garnet and then
stepford and stone was Steptoe and son
which was a British show right yeah well
look it you know where the dropping
knowledge you know where the Jeffersons
came along because they had they had
after Archie back on it so the the Black
Panthers visited Norman Lee and they
were like we want you to do a show where
black people are successful everything
else is like stepped off son where
they're like living junkie or else or
else good times he might as well yeah
good times was like poor people all
right
dynomite yeah I still think the greatest
thing ever and rent is easy actually
does it in this in a show but is that
your the George Jefferson walk yeah you
know that that [ __ ] swagger when
George Jefferson walking it's like you
know the brother with money just
cruising up the hill he owed the comedy
club in Albuquerque like he took a ten
thousand dollar advance and never showed
up George Jefferson George Jefferson oh
[ __ ] that's awesome yeah you know what
you need even if he wasn't beforehand
you know in the eighties he became one
[Laughter]
Walker was a Grayson that's what you
know Bruce Jenner has hit rock bottom
when he'll be doing stand-up that'll be
the end it's a real career doing the way
up and the way down the aisle today a
furnace yeah some weird uh one of my
favorite jokes is whenever you play like
a [ __ ] venue there's always it's a hack
joke in England which always has like a
person like like let's call it the
Sheffield broom because it called the
chef ever there's always like something
you say it was good oh it's good being a
chef and I saw you only play it twice in
your career once on the way up once for
the way down nice to see you again go
online get Jim Jefferies tickets if
you're in England go go go Mia Pulver's
Ely all-in tour headlining second stage
Pittsburgh comedy fest at the Rex
Josie Norton and Segura and and then
come see me and me and Paul versus the
aula mentor the Rex Theatre in
Pittsburgh Friday June 26th and I'm on
the bus with bird you know we're birds
that everybody knows what bird is that
all right Jim listen buddy thanks so
much for being here
all right again this is in sensitivity
training I'm court McGowan
I'm Joe Barton air have a great week
guys have a great week guys have a great
week guys have a great week